hi i'm zoe deutsch i'm dylan o'brien and
we're here to take the buzzfeed co-star
test to see how well we really know each
other you have a very good memory so i
don't know you i have a sh
memory i know so we didn't even remember
that we like knew each other
their full birthday august 26th
no i didn't august 26th i didn't google
i don't know what year but i know august
26th you can guess the year
30. you know
you came to my 30th
okay i know what 1990
one
yep i know yours is
well november 11th no 12th 10th
i already lose
well that's 94
yeah so i would have had the year in the
pocket you were close i was still nice
of you that you knew that well your
middle name i think it's the name of why
do i also know this isn't it
yes oh okay great also why do i know
how do you know that i don't know my
full name is zoe francis kaya thompson
deutsch i have three middle names
francis was my great grandmother's name
is my hebrew name thompson's my mom's
maiden name so that just doesn't count
for me because three that's three names
is yeah but it's counted if you got one
for sure yep fair the first time you met
let's throw down brother let's talk
i am so convinced it was at an audition
and i know you don't think that's where
we met but i really feel like we had a
chemistry read for a movie that i didn't
get i thought it was divergent but you
said that that didn't happen that's fine
i accept that but if it wasn't divergent
it was something else i thought that it
was at like a party
we were both with our exes this was
years ago
ran into each other said well hi
the whole foursome like met and said
hello
that's the first thing i remember i'm
totally open to
this audition but if it was like a
chemistry read
those are the things that i feel like i
like remember like all of
any chemistry i've like ever had because
like there's not
many i'm also open to me having created
that memory entirely or maybe it was
like in an audition room or something
yeah see i don't remember any auditions
ever i black it out completely they're
all defensive
it's a protective mechanism that i just
like i have no trauma no good vibes no
bad vibes just auditions like i so i
could have totally made it up but that's
where i thought we met how about we both
get that point
what's your coffee order uh all right
can i riff one for you and see if i
happen to nail it oh yeah iced latte oat
milk actually
anything else in it
you gotta be kidding me sometimes i do a
lot sometimes i do hot yeah what do you
just do a black coffee no
the way i said that like what are you a
loser
i'm sorry you mean bad ass cause it's
black coffee dylan brought his
he brought to london a suitcase phil
that was my when you landed and i was
like what are you doing
i'm unpacking my coffee like brought
coffee smuggled coffee in from america
i'm sure you have to claim that by the
way and you did i brought not just the
coffee i brought my coffee maker
psycho
and i broke it as soon as i got there
because the voltage is different and
like it literally like blew up my coffee
maker i do my own thing at home where i
do a little bit of raw sugar
a little bit of
a little bit of coconut oil
coconut oil okay a little bit of butter
oh you do that when you turn 30
weird like putting butter in your coffee
give me three years and i'll be putting
that in my coffee too i'm sure go to
activity between filming scenes you are
chatty chatty chatty chatty you just
talk to people you're so and you are you
have best friends with everyone you
uh
sing and make noises
i think we both get the point okay your
first role if it counts this i know was
when you would make your youtube videos
and then after that was teen wolf yep
and yours
was beautiful creatures
no it was a
well the critically acclaimed
masterpiece uh the sweet life on deck i
played zach's girlfriend maya big moment
in television
your hometown well weren't you born in
new york city but you where you grew up
was new jersey all right fine um studio
city that's great yes you win your
favorite snack from crafty
you love what's it called that's the
popcorn skinny pop
they didn't have that out in london so
you can take that yours is anything
you eat all of it you're so not picky no
you're just not a picky person in
general like you're not you're not
actory at all you're the least male
actory actor i know which is like a big
compliment you are not you eat anything
it's like you love the welch's grape
snacks that are the only thing that
every set has your dressing room must
have so funny now you are very good at
decking out your dressing room joey has
like character inspiration photos like
collages that she puts together like
candles
snacks spin drifts yes
yes you get that point for sure yours i
don't think you have anything specific
in your dressing room that i remember
i've never
in there favorite scene you shot
together
one we've done two movies together oh
that counts yeah yeah let's do both i
just got a real kick out of the scene
that we shot not okay where you're
smoking that joint in the scene i like
crack up at you
in like a very a ridiculous way and
somebody filmed it from across the
street oh yeah yeah that made it on tick
tock and went like very viral at
millions
literally me zoey just embarrassing
because i'm like
like i laughed
and people were like whoa zoey's like
really
i look back
i choose that too that was really funny
because coming off of this too it was so
did like we were like cracking up just
like the how completely different like
we looked and how completely different
the thing we were doing was yeah so fun
yeah and you're so fun to act with and
so versatile and
i think zoe won
i think you got like 11. well how many
things do you think i don't know seven
seven exactly
i got nine i was gonna say nine i can't
even get that right
you also won at that i had a good time
it was a great time always a good time
with you always have a great time with
you hey viewers thanks for joining go
check out the outfit march 18. we're
both
laughs
[Music]
you